information can be hard to come by and
Ito many in the long choose for basics
like food and tea people exchange news
but it's difficult to tell rumor from
fact a little lovin ladonia some say the
border to Macedonia is going to be
opened again soon others say no it will
stay shut these kinds of rumors make our
situation even more desperate I don't
believe anything anymore what we really
need is official information then the
sharp collab this moment bother but
there isn't any of that not from the
Greek officials directly and not from
the internet which doesn't always work
inside the camp often volunteer
activists are the only people the
refugees can talk to you they help out a
lot and have a lot of influence some say
too much ever since the first leaflets
showed up asking refugees to cross the
border officials have been pointing
their fingers at the activists here in
the camp for spreading rumors and
inciting the refugees even now nobody
really knows who was responsible for
those actions but still police have
arrested many activists in the past few
days right now they are under general
suspicion here in a demeaning we spoke
to a group of German activists they
thought long and hard before agreeing to
give us an interview they say the police
are unjustly hindering them from doing
their work once I take the shower jitsu
kinds fights off how day-to-day work
here is absolutely not about inciting
the refugees in any way that wouldn't
make sense because we're talking about
independent individuals with their own
opinions and their own ability to make
decisions the only thing we're trying to
do is provide basic humanitarian
assistance in this inhumane place things
like tea and food for tyonne that's
assistance that sorely needed by the
some 11,000 refugees who live in the ITO
minicamp